the wendy williams show is set apart
from the other shows because
um
i'm giving the wendy
and
i'm not a polish journalist i'm just a
nosy woman from the suburbs of new
jersey and i want it all
we're making our way through the first
week of the wendy williams show i feel
like uh you know i'm entering a new
chapter in my life
a very necessary chapter and i feel
poised
ready and very supported and
prepared and and
ready to be not just a face in daytime
tv my desire
is to be
america's sweetheart in many ways what i
find is celebrities don't mind giving
exclusives
and talking about some of the things
that might make their lips a little
tight
as long as it's done in a respectful way
and
i know how to do respectful my bark is a
lot worse than my bite
the types of interviews that i'll be
doing with guests are the types of
interviews that i've been giving since
the show started um which were only a
few days in but i'm pretty consistent
with um you know what i'm going to be
doing uh you know it's not about swoop
downs and it's it's not about exposing
and it's not about disrespecting
celebrities wishes and pissing off
publicists but i will be giving the
wendy and i and i think you see that
today in the kim kardashian show
i'm actually not nervous i got over the
hurdle of me totally ripping my dress
moments ago so now that it's all fixed
and sewn i think i'm ready to go i'm not
nervous wendy's amazing so
she um she doesn't intimidate me at all
and chloe has a few words for you too
we'll talk about it later oh she wants
to come on the show okay yeah okay i do
a lot of different things so publishing
and radio and tv i've called myself
queen of all media for many years
but now i feel as though i am actually
coming into my own and this thing could
possibly work out for me that's probably
the biggest obstacle in daytime tv
is
in addition to being able to deliver you
know the personality is um getting right
with yourself on the camera because when
the camera rolls if you're not right
then you're always pulling your clothes
always tweaking all i um
i'm left to do is identify with the
audience and deliver the wendy and um
and so far so good i don't even like to
process the news
that um continues to swirl around this
show
all i want to do is focus on putting out
a good product
i mean i love what's going on in pop
culture you know every day i'm going to
talk about the hot topics
i'm not going to get a big head i'm
going to continue to be wendy you know
i'm a mess but most people are a mass
and
i don't mind talking about the mess that
i am
and perhaps that's one of the things
that people identify
um with me on
you know everybody's got issues i don't
mind sharing mine
and hopefully
america will share theirs with me
[Music]
you